the Islamic state group is spreading its
wave of violence to a new France Libya
its victims were 21 kidnapped Egyptian
migrant workers who were Coptic
Christians slaughtered in a mass
beheading Egyptian president Sisi
seeking Swift revenge bombed is targets
in neighboring Libya within hours but
our airstrikes really the way to defeat
is is are itching for a fight and Arab
leaders are giving it to them
egypt's response has been very familiar
just a few weeks ago Jordan's King
Abdullah bombed is target's after a
fighter pilot was burned alive at the
hands of the same group riding a wave of
grief the army launched airstrikes on is
and King Abdullah was hailed as a badass
by the media both leaders are now
championed as Arab heroes but lost in
the conversation is the impact on these
societies shortly after the pilot was
captured Jordan banned any republication
of is material there was also a media
blackout on news regarding the pilots
capture basically any debate about
Jordan's role in the war became
impossible Egypt no stranger to a state
of emergency deployed the military to
all corners of the country yes after the
brutal killings of their own countrymen
both populations have been galvanized to
support the bombing campaigns an eye for
an eye but the air strikes the target
militants also kill innocent civilians
at least seven civilians including three
children were killed in Egypt say
strikes in Libya is the collateral
damage justifiable Egypt is reporting
exact numbers of is killed with local
media outlets taking reports at face
value
why military interventions have
consequences what happens when there's
blowback more than 1 million Egyptians
are working in Libya some of whom were
reportedly kidnapped after the
airstrikes the turmoil in the Middle
East didn't begin with is if we woke up
tomorrow and is or Isis was gone
Syria Civil War would still be raging
acids barrel bombs won't disappear the
region would still face some of its most
pressing problems is is a threat but it
can never be more than a symptom
decades of war and sectarianism often
fought on behalf of bigger powers
[Music]